this time
i think he's dead
come back bro
come back
i thought she died
there's no other way that she's getting
out of those mountains we're literally
her last hope
but she's not secured
if he's under three and a half minutes
of snow he's dead
native new zealander ryan lucas
and canadian mike roy
[Applause]
[Music]
are experienced kayakers kayaking is
pretty special sport just reading the
water and floating with the river
it's like a dance
23 year old mike first befriended 25
year old ryan on a rafting trip in
british columbia
say ryan to any kayaker and they know
who he is
he was running some really big rapid big
waterfalls
after paddling together a number of
times the friends set their sights on
their next challenge
new zealand's kaimanawa forest park
hidden in the heart of this ancient 191
thousand acre woodland
is the spectacular tauranga taupo
waterfall
the pair undertake a four-hour trek
through dense forest
we kind of got lost a couple times
trying to find a way you have to walk
into a really badly marked trail
it's pretty remote once you're out there
and
you're pretty far from any help
this
is their challenge
an 80-foot high waterfall
two missions in a row
we got some fun on the wood this weekend
yeah look at that
stoked made it when i first started
waterfall i was pretty impressed
but it looks good
we're gonna have to send it
out here there's no cell phone reception
if something goes wrong
they're on their own
the water was really big and pushing
into a wall on the left side of the
waterfall
so i thought that was a little too pushy
to my taste
i was very nervous
the higher the water levels the harder
it is to control the descent
the current pushes the kayak faster
and in more unpredictable directions
ryan thought it was pretty good
he thought he was on the high side but
not too high so
he decided to give it a go
mike hikes down to the base of the falls
where he's got the perfect angle on
ryan's run
i get the shot ready and it looks
absolutely amazing
good
here we go
i'm definitely nervous for this one
we're going to send it
there it goes it's looking really good
here we go
we've got a
camera rolling
i give him a big whistle blast so you
can know that i'm ready
and then he gives a whistle blast back
when he's
going
[Music]
brian sets off on a journey that's only
ever been attempted a handful of times
[Music]
it's been 30 seconds
ryan should have resurfaced by now
i saw this guy roll over the lip he's at
the right spot on the waterfall he's on
the line
but
his ball gets kicked in the air and
he's going down
right away i saw that was not going to
be a soft hit
i saw his cag come out of the water
upside down
usually come back upside down and you
roll over but then he doesn't roll
come
over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
it's pretty hard to get to him
i get trashed on the walls
it's now been two minutes
since ryan went over the falls
he's not moving
ryan has been submerged for two and a
half minutes and is showing no signs of
turning himself over
mike needs to get him out and off to dry
land
i finally just decided to pull him out
of this kayak
and
get him to shore that way
mike tethers ryan to his kayak
i'm super scared
of what's coming next
he might be dead
[Music]
it's now been three and a half minutes
since ryan went over the edge
he's totally blue unconscious blue lips
white there's no life in him
there was already like some foam and
liquid and blood coming out of his mouth
ryan likely slammed his head against the
kayak on landing
mike can't tell if he's just unconscious
or already dead
more than two minutes under water
easily could have drowned
mike hopes against all hope
that it's not too
late come on ryan
come on bro come on come back
come back bro
come back
come back bro
come
[Applause]
on on brother come back
[Applause]
come back
[Music]
come back
come on
extreme kayaker ryan lucas had a bad run
down the 80-foot high toranga taupo
waterfall
and is now unresponsive
his friend mike roy struggles to revive
him
i think he's dead
come back bro
come back
come back bro
come on
read it can you hear me bro
talk to me
i
see his eye moving a little bit
come on brother come on brother talk to
me
talk to me
finally
there's a glimmer of life
breathe in bro
[Music]
i remember not knowing where i was and
what i did i just remember hearing
voices in my head probably mike yelling
at me come on bro
it's not a clear memory but almost been
in and out
of consciousness
cook that water
come on
stay with me bro stay with me
come on
crew get out duke it out
come back to me
come on bro come on bro stay with me
with me bro
[Music]
ryan's alive
but struggles to breathe
he's still at risk
inhaled water can cause the small sex in
the lungs to swell
eventually stopping oxygen from reaching
the bloodstream
death can happen hours
or even days later
you know where you are bro
i remember like grabbing him and just
being like
thank you
i'm worried about his state he just came
back to life
and
we're not in the best position
where we can just call for help stranded
in an isolated canyon
ryan needs professional medical
attention
fast
water in the lungs isn't the only risk
his body could go into shock and
restrict blood flow to just the vital
organs
after an adrenaline dump blood pressure
drops
with potentially fatal results
you can have a big crash two hours trek
from the nearest road with no cell phone
reception
the pair's options
are bleak
first one will be hiking back the way we
came but it's gonna get dark
second option
will be to wait there
and wait until help will come to us but
that will take
too much time and my third option would
be
try to paddle down get to help by
yourself
that option is really scary because
i've never battled the river before
mike decides their only real option is
to paddle down the 17-mile river to find
help
the pair switch off their head cams as
sheer survival becomes the priority
i wasn't peddling very well and i was
out of my mind i just felt so
just dizzy weird and
didn't really know what was going on
an hour and a half later
nightfall
mike brings ryan ashore
and heads off alone to raise the alarm
the call comes in
it's initially for a search it's dark so
immediately it's got complications
it is literally like looking for a
needle in a haystack you're trying to
find a single person in an entire forest
somewhere loosely
based around a river without precise
coordinates the helicopter uses night
vision technology and bright lights to
search for ryan
four and a half hours after the accident
they spotted him
the hallow was hovering over i knew it
was dangerous for them to do it at night
it's too tight a space for the
helicopter to land
ryan switches his head cam back on as
the rescuers hoist him out by winch
get this wrong
and the helicopter can snag a tree and
jackknife
it's a life and death operation for us
it just so happened this is the first
time that we'd operationally done a
night hoist
ryan makes it safely to carpool hospital
where he's treated for lung
complications hypothermia concussion
and damaged ribs
he makes a full recovery and hasn't
allowed the ordeal to get between him
and the sport he loves
we went for a battle actually yesterday
and
it was nice to see him
go he still has the same passion
i'll try and keep my mentality strong
because i still kayak i still love the
kayak and you've got to have a pretty
strong hit on you in the sport
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a prime destination for skiers
and snowboarders
24 year old alice garcia has made the
slopes his home for 15 years
is my passion when you start feeling
that you are
gliding so let us know it's a
very special feeling
alice is a ski instructor on weekends
but during the week he goes up the
mountains with friends around muscle
cecilia and tommy braggerson
the way i met the other guys was just
looking who's a good skier and i saw
lace and with amazing skier and i met up
with iran who is a good friend of elise
as well then we just hit it off the trio
identified the eight thousand seven
hundred foot
as their next challenge
it's a hard difficult phase it's proper
big mountain riding
ten feet of snow has fallen in the past
two weeks
but now the skies are clear
a potentially
lethal combination
as the surface snow reflects the sun's
radiation it crystallizes and loses its
grip on the layers below
it's been two three days since the last
snowfall they're going to open the lift
that will enable us to walk up to
tukdelance
the trio reach the top of the mountain
alice in the red jacket and iran in the
blue sport cameras to record their
descents
500 yards away on an opposite peak
mountain guide roger marturell sees
alice aran and tommy preparing for their
run
we saw three guys going onto that
direction and they were breaking trail
so i thought it was a guide with two
clients
a little bit crusty
i thought that they were taking too many
risks on riding that slope that day
i said to aran go yo first it's your
first time and you do the first thing
three two one dropping
around goes
everything
looks pretty good
ran stays in the left side of the tube
and
there's no look sperm
i decided to film it to then later find
out who was and send them the footage so
because it's super nice point of view
halfway down a sheet of crumbling snow
sweeps pasta
an ominous sign
i wait for about half a minute a minute
and then i go
[Music]
it feels all good
be careful tony
wait wait wait wait wait wait
you can't pull up
let's go down there we're not going to
stay here
no no no no
i wait another 30 seconds from tommy
departure
[Music]
suddenly the mountainside gives way
triggering a massive avalanche
try to outrun it
snowboarders around cecilia and tommy
bragason have started down to
peak in the northern pyrenees
wait wait
but their friend alice garcia has just
skied into a crack near the top of the
slope getting caught in an avalanche
and everything went now
engulfed by snow alice is dragged down
the mountain
i was feeling like zero gravity
i just can't remember the
the flavor or the
of the snow
and white
light and black light
the avalanche as big as the one
that we
encounter is
just not something you cannot run it's
something that kills you
avalanches claim more than 150 lives
every year
a fifth of these victims die from
injuries before the snow even comes to a
rest
[Music]
can see tommy 160 feet down slow
but there's no sign of
you have to get out of the snow within
the first 15 minutes the maximum
alicia's camera has come loose in the
avalanche
leaving it dangling
tommy
come on
alice and tommy have tracking devices
once activated they can find someone up
to 65 feet away
[Music]
aran has already been under the snow for
three minutes
time is running out
[Music]
yeah yeah
stay calm
it is uncertain
[Music]
okay
the tracking device finally says aran is
three and a half meters away eleven and
a half feet but can't pinpoint where
he could be right under foot
eleven and a half feet down
he's almost panicking in a second it's
because he's putting his probe down he's
like he's three and a half meters of
snow here
no i'm not sure
if he's under three and a half meters of
snow he's dead
by now adan has been buried alive for
eight minutes
he's not just in danger of freezing to
death
if he's 11 and a half feet deep it will
take more than two hours to dig him out
nobody is able to survive without fresh
oxygen for more than a few minutes he'll
almost certainly suffocate
from the opposite slope
roger watches the crisis unfold
so i couldn't spot the third one
so i
i just took my radio
and i called the rescue team
they said avalanche size three east face
of laganza peak
and there are three people involved
with adan's chances of survival getting
slimmer by the minute alice and tommy
keep trying to pinpoint his location
[Music]
here one 1.5
i took my probe and in the second probe
then we touched something 50 centimeters
deep
[Music]
and then i realized i don't have a
shovel i don't have a probe
tommy's fall down the mountain tore his
backpack open causing all his safety
gear to spill out
[Music]
come on
with just one shovel between them alice
and tommy must furiously dig their
friend out of his snowy grave
tommy bragason and alice garcia have
finally found their friend aran maso
cecilia buried deep under heavy snow
come on
aran has now been buried alive
for almost 10 minutes
we found his hand and we found his mouth
i can feel that he was breathing
yep
[Music]
unknown injuries
they need help getting him off the
mountain but elise lost his skis in the
avalanche
i realized that it's me who's gotta go
run for help
i make it about 200 meters and then the
helicopter flies over my head
roger's call from across the mountain
range has brought the helicopter from
via rescue service
with a five-man team
the rescue team knows the snow is
unstable
another avalanche could be minutes away
rapido
two minutes of frantic shoveling and
aran is finally freed from his tune
relax
yesterday
going
[Music]
my
had it not been for elise and tommy's
quick thinking
aran may not have made it off the
mountain alive
hospital for back chest rib and muscle
injuries
it takes two weeks to get back on his
feet
but what the three friends went through
will never be forgotten
these experiences might feel for for
life i think
oh oh
i almost died
my friend almost died
and we were all
extremely close to saying goodbye on
that day
[Music]
is
these mountains are almost entirely
wooded and famous for their waterfalls
which makes them a magnet for
experienced hikers
like 24 year old shelby fanning and her
longtime friend 23 year old sarah nash
i met shelby on the college crew team we
both were
involved in um high level sports and
we bonded over that
she really wanted to do some harder
hikes so she asked me to be
her training buddy
the pair identifies gothic basin as the
perfect place to start
it's a tough nine-mile trail bounded by
steep rock walls on all sides
with foggy lake sitting 5000 feet above
sea level
i hiked gothic basin before
that i think was one of the
hardest hikes i've ever done
and most dangerous
snohomish county sheriff's office is
alerted to an accident on gothic basin
so the call came in
we had a
young adult female with a broken leg the
caller is sarah
shelby fell down a steep slope by foggy
lake
it took sarah two and a half hours to
hike down the mountain to call for help
i thought she would have died
she was going
so quickly and then
in a few seconds
i heard this
snap
and then
she screamed my name and the way she
said it
was just terrifying
there's no way you can drive back there
there are no roads if we had to go by
ground to go rescue someone it could
take days
the five-person crew scours the terrain
for shelby
there's no other way that she's getting
out of those mountains we're literally
her last hope
four hours ago hiker shelby fanning
plunged down a steep slope in the
cascade mountains
and snapped a bone in her leg
the helicopter rescue team is struggling
to find her
there's no other way that she's getting
out of those mountains we're literally
her last hope
with nightfall just a few hours away and
temperatures only getting colder the
team have no time to lose the area is
very remote it's very rugged
we had a fairly
large snowfall so we knew that we're
going to have snow all the way down well
below that elevation
it's past 5 p.m
shelby has now been lying alone
in agony
for four and a half hours
she must have been so
scared and was probably in like the
darkest
time of her
life
just
sitting there
in distress
i saw
a gray tarp that was kind of fluttering
that motion kind of caught my eye
shelby slipped down a 50 degree slope
before coming to rest on a nest of
branches
perilously close to a sheer drop-off
she'd gone two feet further she would
have fallen over that cliff to certain
death
the mountain is steep icy and covered in
trees
there is nowhere safe to land
a helicopter rescue tech will typically
go down first to make sure that the
scene is safe
you really don't know until your boots
hit the ground of exactly what you're in
for
with no clearing to aim for and a steep
cliff directly below shelby
the rescue team has to make dude with a
spot 15 feet upslope
the place that was available for us to
safely land there was probably literally
one foot by two feet
in a spot and you're talking about
trying to land a human being there from
80 maybe 90 feet in the air using a
cable that's attached to a helicopter
that is constantly moving around
it's 50 or 60 degrees
in
steepness and so you have only a short
amount of time to recover if you have a
misstep
andy's never been to this part of the
mountain before
and has no idea how dangerous the ground
may be
everything that i was doing was trying
to be
extra cautious
he carefully tests the surface
kicking makeshift steps down to shelby
medic brian is next
[Music]
whatever you're looking at from the air
always looks a lot flatter than when you
actually set foot on it
they're dangerously positioned on a
vertical ice slope
andy's plan is to anchor to the tree
between them and shelby
so they don't fall over the cliff
themselves
can you hear me okay
okay the risk that i'm concerned about
is the thin
bridge with the whoever running over it
next to shelby is a steep waterfall
partially covered in snow
andy fears the path to her overhanging
the waterfall and cliff
could be unstable
if i slip
uh in that snow i go into the waterfall
and then uh i'm the next fatality
if i say no we hoist out of there and go
home and reevaluate our plan
hiker shelby fanning has fallen in the
cascade mountains and is stranded with a
broken leg on some branches above a
steep drop
the snohomish county helicopter rescue
team is on the scene but reaching shelby
may be a step too far
even for them are you comfortable
if i say no we hoist out of there and go
home and reevaluate our plan
okay
they slowly descend the temporary steps
and he kicked in
then
the medical kit is set down
[Music]
you want to make sure that whatever
you're doing isn't going to fall on top
of her and knock her off into the
waterfall
[Music]
[Music]
five and a half minutes after landing on
the mountainside
o'brien reaches shelby
they
were the first sign of hope
i just burst into tears
this was a life or death situation
i was more concerned for her position
than i was for her injury she was laying
on a tree bow on the edge of a cliff
and she wasn't secured to it in any way
though the branches have held out under
her weight they could snap at the
slightest movement
i constantly felt like i was slipping
off either to the left or the right and
kind of was holding on
for what felt like dear life
it was so cold and i was shivering the
entire time
as you succumb to hypothermia that
shivering will start to decrease and
that's kind of where she was at that
definitely adds a level of criticality
to the situation and just talking out
loud brian but she's not secured
right
okay
with shelby hypothermic they need to get
her out of the cold as soon as possible
i'm gonna say 20 minutes
but first andy needs time to safely set
up the stretcher
you have to have all those pieces
somewhat anchored as you're putting them
together i'm going to slide this down
all right
andy sends the stretcher down to brian
making sure that it's tethered to the
tree above them
to get shelby on the stretcher andy has
to step onto the tree canopy
if the branches break all three could
tumble down the cliff face
i could feel that there was uh
definitely some give to the branches
that it wasn't like a solid block of
concrete that we were on i certainly
wasn't going to jump up and down on them
i knew that when i moved her it was
going to hurt a lot and a lot of times
when people hurt
they produce involuntary movements in
response to the pain and that
involuntary movement could have sent her
over the edge of the cliff
i was very scared about having to be
lifted up i just knew the pain was going
to be so intense
any movement was going to move that leg
around and cause further injury so it's
kind of a trick because you need to get
her into that basket quickly but you
also need to do it without doing any
additional harm you have to be really
careful
nice the pair fastened shelby onto the
stretcher so that she's also anchored to
the trees
we got her secured in the litter was
definitely a sire relief and i was
definitely concerned about her falling
off of that uh cliff before we were able
to get her out of there
but the operation
isn't over
if andy and brian tried to lift shelby
out of the tree and on to firmer ground
for the hoist
the branches could give way
leaving them all hanging from the anchor
okay patient is packaged in place uh
we did not move her and are unable to
move from there
so we're wanting to extract from that
location
the rescue team is faced with no option
but to hoist shelby directly from the
branches
we couldn't just do our normal operation
where we just pick them straight up if
we did that she would have just hit tree
branch after tree branch and so what
they had to do was kind of go off at an
angle as she was being lifted to make
sure that she cleared that safely
when we finally hoisted shelby into the
aircraft that was the point where i was
thinking to myself there was a very good
chance that this was going to come off
successfully
shelby is treated in the hospital for
hypothermia and multiple fractures of
the leg
it could have been much worse
had it not been for the rescue team it's
been a little over a year now
and i can do most things that i was able
to do i still can't run
i haven't gone hiking since i haven't
done a lot of things i don't know any of
my friends that have been in a situation
like that and i hope to god they're
never in a situation like that because
that's
that was horrible
[Music]
you